you
all right hi I'm Aaron and I am a data
engineer at Spotify and I'm going to
talk to you today about unified pipeline
architecture and how we have evolved the
data processing and Spotify from the old
model to this what we called unified
architecture so I will actually
introduce Spotify in case you're not
familiar with it so this is what Spotify
is it's essentially a music player you
can add there's a desktop version phone
version and anyone can have an account
you can listen there's a free version
premium version might look like this
so however on creator which is the team
that I'm on our main customer is
actually not a consumer but the artist
so we create a platform for artists that
we call Spotify for artists and what it
is it's essentially a dashboard that
allows the artists to see some metrics
about how well their music is doing them
Spotify and I'm going to show you a
quick demo
so as this fan insights I'm beetles so I
want to see how many listeners I have so
I can see kind of over time how many
listeners I have shows you some
statistics about the fans as well as
what context on Spotify people listen
from so like Spotify playlists etc what
the demographics of your listeners are
who else they listen to so you can think
of it as like artists who are similar to
you you might want to have a new concert
this opener how they listen across
different geographies it's kind of
color-coded by the number of listeners
as well as top cities you can then drill
down and you can go on the song page
will show you all of your tracks or top
200 tracks that you have on Spotify and
you can see here kind of which you know
by streams and by number of listeners
which ones are the most frequently
listened track
so for instance if we want to see how
this one is doing here comes the Sun you
can see over the last several timeframes
how many listeners you have how many
streams how many saves and kind of the
same informations you saw in the artist
page you can also see which playlists
this song is in so yeah so that's that's
SFI so ISIF eye is a very large
dashboard and we try to provide as much
analytics for the artists as we can so
it poses a very interesting data problem
for us so how do we actually build this
dashboard we have four data we have one
primary source that we derive all the
data from and I'll mention this source a
lot so I wanted to present it it's
called end song so the end song is
essentially a log message so every time
that you finish listening a song for
whatever reason either because the next
one started or because the new song
starts in the playlist or because you
just skipped or you know skipped
immediately will create a log message
called end song it contains certain
information about the track so we kind
of know where you were listening at from
so that's play context as well as the
location of the person listening user ID
and track ID and from that we try to
drive most useful for most of the
information that you saw in the
dashboard is actually derived from this
we have a couple of secondary sources so
we can also you know you can imagine we
probably have some sort of metadata that
explains kind of what the track
information is what the user information
is playlists information etc when we set
out building this we had a system and
actually the system that you saw is
powered by the current architecture the
current architecture was built actually
about a year ago so we talked about
evolution that's not that it's actually
very recent so the way that that was
built as you can think of
like classic MapReduce there is you have
a data endpoint which is a set of data
it's a data set and you have independent
code paths that compute intermediary
sources for each data set each endpoint
has about three to six intermediate
computation stages and the way that it's
designed it's kind of tailored towards
what you're trying to compute so
intermediate data is not very usable it
has a lot of advantages it is extremely
flexible because every time that you
need to build a new pipeline you just
build it from scratch you compute what
you need kind of from the from the
ground truth and it's a dot then other
nice thing is this adaptable to many
changing requirements so the
requirements change and you interchange
one thing you only have to change it in
one pipeline however it does have some
issues so the issues you can imagine
with such a setup this end song for
instance that I referred to you have to
read it very many times because every
single path of the execution you have to
read it once to compute everything you
need to compute the multi-layered
dependencies cause cascading effects if
there are any issues or delays and I'll
go a little bit in depth about what that
is and it can also cause datum
consistencies so first thing I want to
talk to you about is redundant
dependencies so this is for our pipeline
orchestration we use Luigi I don't know
if you're familiar with it but it's an
open source project so this shows you a
Luigi execution a sample Luigi execution
so say we want to compute that end point
up at the top in order to compute that
we need to actually compute everything
that's in the second row in order to
compute everything in the second row we
need to compute everything in the third
or etc so as you can imagine if that
source right there is delayed where that
end point is delayed it causes the
cascading effect so in this particular
case we're trying to compute one of our
definitions of fan is you need to
actually look at the listener history
for last 182 days
so that's why this has as many sources
as it has because we are aggregating
daily where I could get monthly into
weekly and then aggregate into monthly
so this is a dashboard that we have
internally which shows us how our
endpoints are doing if they're done
computing so in this case it's in a good
day 10 a.m. so we operate our days or
end in UTC so this is 10 a.m. in the
u.s. is what like I don't know 2 p.m.
UTC or something hopefully I'm doing my
math right so anything that's green is
done those are all the endpoints that
need to compute every day anything
that's green is done anything that the
blue is currently executing everything
that's gray hasn't even started
executing so you can imagine that if you
have such cascading in fact what happens
if one of your sources is delayed or one
of your computations failed or died for
whatever reason the source up at the top
that depends on it
will not complete until much later so
that's kind of so that's a good day so
ideally by 8:00 a.m. UTC if we want to
be done so realistically that's not the
case the other thing it can cause is
data inconsistency so in this case we
have an artist who has one single track
and this track happens to be at a
playlist so here you can see the
playlist information it shows you the
number of listeners that you have
overall from all your tracks and here
you have just the list of all the songs
so as you can see the numbers are very
different and the result well there's
probably some assumption one of these
pipelines that got propagated and as a
result we got different results that's
not ideal so it's kind of you know in
the current architecture that's kind of
you can think of it this way so you have
the end song which is our source and
from there it computes completely
disjointed paths so when you have
something like the playlist example I
was just alluding to
you have listener by song might be that
red dot right there
and listener by playlist might be over
there and then it gets aggregated
further and that causes this and overall
it looks something like this so when we
set out to rebuild this architecture
which has been a project we've been
working on for a while with a team my
team we wanted to see is can we read it
source only once so if we have a single
source it's kind of redundant to keep
reading it many times especially if it's
quite large which in our case our
inseong is how can we reduce the
computation time and in this case it's
not even the actual time of the pipeline
takes to run but can we make it so that
more things run in parallel so that
there's fewer things that actually need
to run can we join all the secondary
sources as they come in rather than
waiting until the end of the day so can
we essentially pre compute certain
things as we know that what they are and
on the flip side the big advantage of
the old system was that it's very
flexible so we want to be able to retain
the flexibility to add new datasets or
new fields so the new architecture what
we call it unified architecture looks
kind of like this now what does this
mean and I mean I'll go in much more
depth but in from the high level you
have your source you get thread and once
then you have a bunch of intermediary
computation stages that denormalize the
data but then we bring them back
together so essentially any pair of keys
or any aggregation we do only once and
then we bring it back together to
actually compute the final results so we
compute everything at the artist level
and at the track level so that's the at
the high level in the architect our new
architecture has these components it has
our sources of course it has what we
call entities and it has data sets and
it has exports and I will now talk to
you a little bit more about what those
are so this is the overall architecture
diagram and as you can see the
the information flows from top down so
that means there's no kind of
dependencies going sideways or up so we
avoid any circular things we might want
to do and the raw data gets we compute
the track the entities layer from
entities layer we compute the datasets
layer and finally we have the exports
layer which is just the logic abstract
and away into what database technology
were using I spoke to you a little bit
about what raw data is so that's you
know and song and any metadata entities
we decided to split our data into kind
of four main sets of data so we have
track data and track user data and the
interesting difference here is we want
to be one of the primary statistics that
we're computing is unique and listeners
in order to compute unique number of
listeners over various time frames we
actually need to keep track of who the
users are that listen to this track or
to this artist so for that we need a
track user entity and the same thing for
artists and as you can see here too we
actually use because we know which
tracks the artist has we're able to then
once we have computed the track user
entity we're able to compute the artists
user and see from there just using that
knowledge from artists user we compute
artists because it's a essentially
collapsed version of that and from track
user a compute track from there we go
into data sets and the data sets we have
two fundamental data sets that we
compute we have the track data set and
the artists data set and what those are
is basically any information that we saw
in the dashboard that I showed you the
SFI essentially just in a single blob of
data finally the exports we have the
thing with the final storage is it might
change we the requirements might change
the latency requirements might change
whatever so
we wanted to abstract that in a separate
layer that's separate from any of the
computation logic and the data structure
logic so that lives in a separate layer
[Music]
few important things about our pipeline
architecture Spotify recently decided to
partner with Google and use the Google
suite of products the computing engine
products so we use the Google Cloud
Storage is essentially their cloud file
storage
we use Google dataflow which is their
computation mechanism and we use
datastore as our database technology to
put our data into the backend the
framework that we use we use Scala and
geo which is built on top of Google's
data flow and for schema we use further
buffs what it so I'll talk a little bit
about shio shio is actually a framework
that was built in-house at Spotify it's
an open source product it is built
it's a scholar set of libraries and
tools that lets you write Google
dataflow jobs but in scala and for us
it's been very powerful for various
reasons it has seen provides seamless
integration with all of the Google suite
of products like bigquery BigTable data
store and it has unified batch and
streaming model which is great and of
course with that we get all the
advantages of scala as well just a
simple example to show you how simple
things are to write in shio we have here
a word canonical word count example I'm
sure you've all seen this but
essentially this is all the logic that
you need to write in order to do the
word count you
so one of the important components of
this architecture was the choice of
using protobufs protobufs
is you know one of the ways to define
schemas you also can use ro parquet we
chose proto pops because they provide a
lot of flexibility and very seamless
scheme evolution system that allows you
to define something very compactly and
it compiles into Scala so you can use it
kind of inside your pipelines the reason
I think it's very important that we use
something like protobufs rather than
just using say scala case classes is
because it allows us to define your very
sophisticated complicated nested
structure with repeated fields and tree
structures etc and we can still just
have this one single thing that we build
in a single stage of the pipeline and
kind of propagate it further so yes so
this is kind of the more in-depth
version of the architecture diagram you
can see here we have so the input stream
we get this and song record we take all
of the other data sources that we have
set in this case I highlighted metadata
collection playlist we join them all
together so what we get from that is we
get a stream of all the information we
need to compute the antitype line we
want to run what what is so entities
pipeline is essentially you take all the
information that you have and you a
granade it at just a raw level so for
instance you know if I wanted to figure
out how many people in New York City
maybe I will go to every single borrow
and within every single borrow maybe
I'll count the number of people in every
building you know so this is kind of a
very abstracted no business logic
whatsoever wrong way to pre aggregate
the data so we just don't get this giant
massive amount of data to deal with from
and from that you know as I mentioned we
compute the four different types of
entities
here you you can see the dependencies
from from each other that they have the
artist user and track user entities a
static entity so it's the idea is you
only have to look at it at one single
entity every single day when you compute
the datasets because the idea is the
dataset layer we want it to be very fast
so if we are able to compute the
entities every single hour by the virtue
of having done this every hour computing
this bloated data set every hour by the
time that the day is done and we've
computed twenty four components of 24 of
those slices we get into data sets and
the data sets with very little data to
process because all we have is this the
track user entity which is the biggest
one as you can imagine this is
historical every track cross every user
so it can do multiple terabytes probably
but we only have to process one of them
the Yaqui part here is if you have to
join them because if you have to join
this massive data set with another one
of those it gets very slow so when and
the entities have done the data sets run
once a day the difference between track
user entity and track entity is that the
track and see is cumulative data so that
might be number of streams per the type
of person listening so we actually agar
have 24 different slices of those we
take all of those by artist or by track
and we compute the data set from there
so this just shows you kind of bird's
eye view if you will on what this
pipeline might look like and this is the
drawing provided by google for us so it
still has many as you can see you know
there's many stages so there might be
like so this is probably join I can't
really read too well but this is a join
there's another join the map aggregate
by key etcetera so it's all the the
standard things that you might think of
in a standard pipeline so what does an
entity look like
an entity has a key which is a very
denormalized view of this data so in
this case you have an artist ID along
with gender information age location
type of listener so type of listener
being like new repeated fan followers
that are and play source being like
collection playlists etc along with
stats and stats is any information that
we want to keep like number of skips
number of saves number of streams number
of starts stream started cetera whatever
you can think of the way to think about
it is if you have all these and songs
and you apply those different types of
filters or aggregations on top of it you
know if say you want to take a slice
from it and in this case male in this
particular age range from Brazil and the
listener type fan you would only get a
subset of this so each one of these keys
is the summation of all of these but
each one of these keys is kind of in
this do normalized table the data set
layer looks very very different the data
set layer is our canonical hierarchical
structure of what our data actually
looks like so this is kind of gets to
the crux of what why this unified
architecture is good because if we in a
single pipeline can compute this whole
structure okay so what we can then
create the logic that will write it into
a database kind of the whole thing or we
can extract certain things to write in a
certain other parts in database so the
flexibility is built into this tree
structure and the way that it's
structured is you have an artist or
track at the top from there you have
your geographical information so we want
to be able to aggregate either globally
by country by city within each of those
you have all the different data sets
that we show and this is from what I
showed you it's essentially the type of
graph or chart that we're building so
you have demographics timeline listener
context and
list of top cities from there you might
have so for instance for demographics
you might have the reason there's two of
them
is because you have like one of them
might be male the other might be female
and age and within that we bacon kind of
the types of listeners here so within
each of these data sections you'll have
all the different types of listeners
that we care about within that you have
different types of data that you store
in there so number of listeners streams
save skips as well as the different time
frames we want to compute it for so one
day seven days 28 days in all time and
how does that actually work in our case
we can then use this to you know
essentially traverse a tree and look at
the leaf node to be able to compute one
of these data graphs so in this case I
want to know what my listeners are in
Brazil and they want to know the top
cities in Brazil and I care I want to
know new listeners in the last seven
days so you can see how in the tree that
will show you that particular slice
information or demographic graph so in
the demographics you want to show all
the demographics by gender so you look
at both demographic slices and kind of
the same thing so you go to repeat
listeners in this case and over the past
28 days so you know this gives you a lot
of flexibility so if we add a new
statistic we don't have to rewrite any
of the pipeline's all we have to do is
because we have the logic for
computation of listeners by all the
different time phrases essentially in
the function we can just add the logic
so say now we want to compute it by you
know last six months we just add the
logic to our function to compute the
last six months and that's it so the
whole tree will then get that
information kind of for free into it
which is which is I think it's extremely
powerful
so finally we have this data store
that's stored in a protobuf at this
point and we want to actually export
into database the data store is the
solution that we use for that data store
the nice thing about data stores it
provides a it's it's a key vow but it
gives you a hierarchical above a
hierarchical structure so you can do
things like this so in this case we're
using ancestral relationships in the
data store to define the structure so in
this case we have the artist which and
the artist has a bunch of different
tracks and within the artist we store
timeline information keyed by year and
the blob of the rest of the data just
stored by date and the same thing for
track and the things that you can do
with structure like that you can say
give me all the tracks for artists acts
which will then give you all of this
without you necessarily having to store
it in a single structure so in
conclusion you know we think that
unified pipeline architecture is
extremely powerful because it allows you
to consolidate you logic and to paralyze
your processing based on the de
normalized data so you minimize the
number of joins very large joins with
big data sets and you can read the
sources only once and decorate them for
further processing and essentially it
allows you to kind of think about the
future and flexibility